the zimmermann and writer paper that uh
that resulted i wish that we were
talking about with the with the decrease
in near-infrared radiation that we're
being exposed to over time since
basically since before the industrial
revolution since we've moved more and
more inside with more and more
protection
from the sun
they basically they propose what we've
now already been talking about but their
hypothesis is published in 2019
is let me just give a little back up is
that melatonin and sunlight are linked
we know this
but melatonin comes in two forms i've
already said this but i just want to be
very
formal about it circulatory and
subcellular which have very different
relationships with the sun so the
hypothesis that they propose in this
2019
paper that's published in the journal
that i had never heard of before called
melatonin research
is
circulatory melatonin is produced in
response to the absence of sunlight and
subcellular melatonin is produced in
response to the presence of sunlight
which itself is
you know remarkable that the same
hormone is going to be produced by
opposite
opposite triggers you know the sa it's
the same input and it's it with a binary
state of yes there is or no there isn't
and in each of those states a different
a different source of the melatonin is
triggered to produce it now i will bet
that there is
a elegant story
that unites these things that it's not
just contradictory but it's a little bit
like you know the uh the result
um
uh that the triggering of your body by
adrenaline
it activates certain things it speeds up
your mental processing for example and
shuts down your gut right is it an up
regulator or a down regulator well it's
a i'm running from that scary thing
regulator and yeah
and the point is different thing you
know some things get put uh put off in
that circumstance and other things get
amped up
and my guess is going to be that the
reason that melatonin is showing up in
both places and the reason that the
pattern is inverse is going to be one of
these like hey that's your your awake
system and then
etc by the way your awake system would
need to know something about your sleep
system and vice versa right exactly so
here's just a couple of paragraphs from
near the end of this 2019 paper
published in melatonin research and you
can show my screen if you like zack
sunlight and the optical properties of
our surroundings guaranteed that for
millions of years most cells in the
human body especially in children were
always exposed to predominantly
near-infrared photons during the day and
for 600 000 years as groups gathered
around the campfire in the evening
before bedtime
this continued for the last 150 years
based on the excessive amounts of
near-infrared radiation emitted by
incandescent bulbs
50 years ago fluorescent bulbs started
to eliminate near-infrared from the
artificial environment but the
incandescent lights continued to provide
near-infrared especially in homes
recent government mandates have begun a
process that will for the first time in
the history of our species eliminate
most of the near-infrared exposure that
once dominated
these changes are being driven by
government mandates and will be
universally implemented over the next
couple of decades with 90 of our time
under artificial lighting and in front
of displays that emit zero near-infrared
and with near-infrared blocking window
treatments preventing near-infrared from
entering our offices schools and homes
modern societies have created
near-infrared caves
as figure s9 illustrates most
researchers are aware that we are
eliminating night by exposing ourselves
to excessive amounts of visible emission
in our signage street lights headlights
lighting computer screens and displays
what most researchers did not realize is
that for the first time
seventy percent of the spectrum emitted
by the sun through near in the form of
near infrared is being eliminated from
our lives during the day
just one more thing
as the round-up lawsuits clearly
illustrate there is an added level of
responsibility and liability associated
with globally altering the public's
environment
as shown above the human body has
evolved and adapted processes based on
the assumption that it is exposed daily
to a single predominantly near-infrared
broadband fixed emitter the sun
that assumption is no longer valid over
the next several decades the government
will convert all lighting to
visible-only emitters with little
understanding as to the long-term health
consequences
or stated otherwise
hyper novelty is a cold [ __ ]
and i thought actually
there's much more to do here but i
thought actually to read the epilogue to
our book here because it fits we didn't
we didn't know this yeah when we wrote
this book um this is
a hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century um we didn't know what i just
read
here
and oh actually one more just show that
final screenshot from the medcram video
zack
if you would before i read the epilogue
here
um
he says we need to start doing
randomized controlled trials on sunshine
exposure
being outside and wouldn't wouldn't that
be a thing yeah right wouldn't that be a
thing and it would be um cruel and
inhuman to restrict some people to
inside if almost everyone weren't doing
that to themselves already anyway
all right okay this is the afterward
uh it's just two pages uh from
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century
in january of 2020 so just a reminder um
we
submitted the first draft of this book
in march of 2020 just before
lockdowns began from covid and of course
it went through a you know a number of a
number of reviews and edits and such
but this book was written the fast bulk
of this book was written before covet
was a known thing but the afterward was
written afterwards
in january of 2020 we went to the
tippatini biodiversity station in the
ecuadorean amazon to finish our first
draft of this book when we emerged from
our isolation as our phones came alive
for the first time in two weeks we were
confronted with a barrage of news mostly
trivial of which we have been blissfully
unaware
but in that onslaught there was one
ominous report a case of a novel
coronavirus in ecuador the pathogen came
from horseshoe bats had jumped to people
and then spread rapidly first in wuhan
china and then beyond
as the two of us tried to make sense of
these first hints of pandemic it quickly
became clear that there might be more to
the story
wuhan we soon learned housed a bsl4
laboratory it was in fact one of our
planet's two main centers of research on
bat-born coronaviruses
these viruses were being studied in
wuhan in north carolina because of fear
among scientists that such viruses could
jump to people and without very much
evolutionary change cause a dangerous
pandemic if nothing else the fact of the
pandemic having begun in one of two
cities where these viruses have been
under intensive studies seemed
spectacular coincidence
as of the writing of this note in late
may 2021 the consensus in the scientific
establishment including national and
international regulators and in the
mainstream press that follows them has
finally shifted to one of grudging
acceptance of the obvious i will say
that it has since shifted backwards
somewhat
um sarsko v2 may well have leaked from
the wuhan institute of virology and the
covert 19 pandemic might therefore be
for humanity an entirely self-inflicted
wound
the strength of this hypothesis is
something we have been discussing on our
podcast darkhorse since april of 2020.
those discussions caused a great deal of
derision and stigma to be directed at us
and it is a bewildering relief to watch
the world suddenly come around the
plausibility of this well-supported if
unfortunate explanation
but no matter what humanity ultimately
concludes about this pandemic's origin
there is a deeper truth hovering just
outside our collective awareness
covert 19 is a product of technology no
matter what path it took to humans
consider this fact
from the beginning of the pandemic the
virus showed essentially zero capacity
to transmit outside
put another way copen 19 is a disease of
buildings cars ships trains and
airplanes
more than 99 of the earth's surface is a
coded safe zone
even in your own backyard the virus will
struggle mightily to infect anyone it
has no meaningful impact unless you
caught it before you walked out in the
park on the balcony at the beach we are
at least for now immune
the dependence of the virus on enclosed
spaces also means that had humanity
agreed to avoid these vectoring
environments for a few weeks the
pandemic could have been quickly brought
to a halt
but this scenario in which we free
ourselves and lock down dangerous
environments instead is little more than
an idle thought experiment
even though in evolutionary terms these
dangerous environments are all brand new
to humans the idea of humanity staying
outside of them even for just a few
weeks is unthinkable
many individuals could do it but the
majority would be at a total loss even
though we evolved outside and despite
the fact that most of our ancestors
would have spent every hour of their
lives in what we now strangely call the
outdoors
we have forgotten the skills we once
knew so well that knowledge of and
comfort with our natural environment has
been replaced with a different skill set
one tuned to pursuing value and avoiding
harm in a synthetic environment of our
own device
our cognitive software has been
rewritten and we have forgotten too much
to ever again be what we were
as a result we are condemned to battle
this pathogen in bespoke environment
environments and which we and it have
been both grown to depend
that's the view on the ground but the
human dimension of this pandemic is even
clearer from thirty thousand feet or
more accurately at 30 000 feet
for it is the way that we have begun to
travel that really set us up for
pathogenic disaster
sars kobe 2 crossed oceans and hours and
it didn't pioneer some ingenious new
mode where once an epidemic might have
been held back by barriers that limit
human travel humans now regularly
transmit communicable diseases from
their continents of origin to every
corner of the globe
much as people thought little about
washing their hands prior to the germ
theory of disease we give no thought to
the scale of misery caused by a given
person transporting a new and nameless
cold virus to some continent that was
free of it the day before
novel coronavirus took advantage of that
nonchalance before the pathogen even had
a proper name
the coven-19 pandemic is itself a
symptom of another disease entirely in
the pages of this book we call that
disease hyper novelty
it is caused by a rate of technological
change so rapid that transitions in our
environment outstrip our capacity to
adapt
you will not find the coven 19 pandemic
specifically dissected here but you will
find a full exploration of the hyper
novelty crisis that left us vulnerable
to this virus a virus so weak that it
could have been cured with a bit of
well-coordinated fresh air
so
patient again
i think yeah not uh
it's a little bit
it's a little bit chilling
uh
to hear that analysis from was it may
2021 yeah we wrote that in may of 2021
um yeah it's uh you know
yeah
i
hate to keep patting ourselves on the
back but uh prescient again
um at many different levels you know um
so
we are where we are i wonder where we'll
be a year from now indeed indeed
[Music]
you